Hello everybody!
My name is Markiplier,
and welcome to Alone.
[illegible ingame noise]
Hi?
Hello?
Okay, so as soon as I loaded in the game
there was a bit of backstory..
I'm here to help a situation,
I can't breathe,
and everything's gone to shit.
As is evident by this guy over here.
Hi, how you doin'?
Oh, you don't look so good.
Do you need medical attention?
You look like one of the people from SOMA.
That the SOMA machines started to already take over.
Which is not good.
And also, there's a lot of weird sounds.
And also I thought I heard something that was from
SCP Containment Breach.
But..
[Female AI]"Hull Breach detected. Sector D-2,
Portside. In vicinity of crew quarters.
Advise use of plasma welder.
Proceed with caution.
Multiple mobile biomasses emitting ionizing radiation.
Present on D-Deck.
Recommended use of standard issued Geiger Counter
To avoid contraction of ARS."
I don't know what ARS is. [It's Acute Radiation Syndrome]
Okay, hi?
Alright, I'll get a move on!
I'll skidaddle on out of here.
And also there's radiation.
Did I mention that there's radiation?
And I'm an engineer of some sort..
So, I'm assuming that my expertise
is gonna get me out of here.
Or maybe I need to go through
these son-of-a-bitch doors.
Oh!
Lovely.
Oh, this doesn't look deathly
at all.
Oh, I feel very confortable in these hallways.
Oh, I'm sure my friends are gonna-
(gas pipe noise)
Come pourin' outta the walls at any moment.
Kay', so I'm assuming I need to use
the Geiger Counter to try to know
where they are.
But I don't know where I am.
eugh
"Cryo Storage"?
"Mess Hall",
"Infirmary",
"Bridge".
AUGH
ECK
I don't know where any of this is.
My arrow seems to be pointing towards the
brid-no, not the bridge.
Seems to be pointing towards..
"Quarters" Oh, okay.
I need to go to the quarters.
That's what-aw crap.
[super sexy scared face 10/10]
Hi?
Is anybody there?
Alright i'ma go in the hole!
Oh, I've never felt more comfortable being in a hole!
What do I need to interact with?
What the hell is in front of me?
Long interaction?
I DON'T KNOW WHAT THAT MEANT!
WHAT DID THAT MEAN?
Where am I?
What am I doing?
Oh, jeez.
Hello?
That's just a loop..
I'm gonna be stuck forever down here.
Hello?
I can't go up this way!
Maybe I shouldn't have gone
in the goddamn vents!
Maybe I should've been a little-
what is that?
What am I interacting with?
Okay..
Alrighty then.
I'm outta here.
Doesn't seem to be anything in here.
Nothing on the Geiger Counter,
so I'm assuming I'm gonna be okay.
Or, generally gonna be okay.
I mean, I'm gonna die.
That's evident.
But at least for now..
I'm gonna be kind of okay.
Hello-hi?
Hello?
Anybody home?
[Female voice coming from radio]"I don't like this.
Should've been smooth sailing
until we were in [illegible] orbit.
This early wake up call has everyone
on edge.
We're still facing rumors that someone's
[illegible] saw something.
Medical has to put the poor boy into a chemically induced coma.
Most just think's he's suffered from some-mental
break, but-
Ugh I don't know.."
Fuckin' fuck.
[Radio voice] Keep my head down for the time being.
I'm starting to wish I hadn't been chosen for this unit."
Okay?
Well yeah I-I'm starting to
wish that I hadn't been brought on here.
Why am I always the engineer that
gets brought onto the death-defying
alien infected ships?
Am I as a clark?
Is that who I is?
Oh, that one's already open.
Why am I even tryna' bother?
Ooh Hi!
You feeling ill?
Are you missing some inteSTINES?
oh boi
My objective marker is telling me
somewhere over here,
but I have no idea where.
[Loud creaking noise]
That was the loudest TV I've
ever heard!
You sack of shit,
what are you doin' to me?
Doin' a whole lot of nothing,
that's what you're doing.
Hello!
Hi!
Oh good, oxygen.
Apparently I need that.
Okay.
habedi-boop-boop-badoop-boop.
No?
Alrighty-oh jeez.
Okay?
I just locked myself in here.
Why didn't they do that when
the aliens were comin' around?
Kay', I don't need to go to the
mess hall, I need to go over here-
[Loud creaking noise]
Again, the weird sound effect that
sounds like the hole crumpling in
around me.
Don't know if I like that..
Oh!
Well I- I made it!
Oh Boy!
oh boi
oohhhhhh
oooooh~
So, I need to now seal the breach because-
[Loud creaking noise again]
Aah!
That is what that is!
It's the hole crumpling in around us and probably gonna-
kill all of us as soon as soon as
we, let our guard down.
dafaq is that one?
Ohh, oh ok.
Ooh! That why I heard it over here first!
OOH! I CAN SEE SPACE!
Oh! Th-thats a bad thing! Okay.
Don't worry guys! I got this!
Engineering expert over here!
Went to many years!
[Female AI]"Orders are for all active crew
to assemble on the bridge."
uhh,
"Unable to confirm time stamp."
ok.
I don't know if I want to do that.
Oh man,
Oooooh, Space!
Nice!
Thats some quality space there (-Mark 2K16)
Oh jeez, thats not good.
Oh this is not good.
Hello.
hi.
Okay.
Alrighty then.
Is anybody home?
jeez.
Alright,
[boop]
[Male voice coming from radio]" We're close to the armory now.
The access code for D-Deck Armory is:
D 3 9 2 6 7 4 4 0
Hopefully this one is intact, so
that we can lay down some suppresive
fire on the infected.
Maybe then we'll stand a chance."
I...
"I'm tired of this cloak and dagger nonsense.
Don't like seein' them up close neither'.
Too much of a reminder of the people they once were.
If anyone is listening to this recording,
then we didn't make it."
Ok! Thats always nice to hear!
So, the infected kinda spread around everywhere.
It does sound like a dead space sit-
[Loud creaking noise once more]
Sorry.
It does sound like a Dead Space situation going on here.
There is some sort of infectant
and they have to fight him back.
At least these guys seemed to
last a big longer than the Ishimura.
ooh.
Ok, so thats locked off but thats where I need to go.
HEEEEH!
OH!
OH! OH! OH!
I SHOULD HAVE BEEN LOOKING AT MY GEIGER COUNTER!
Hello?
Hello!
Oh jeez, where is he?
I didn't actually think there was
gonna be anything on this ship.
Hello?
Okay.
eee
I hear you.
Where is you?
Okay.
Alrighty then.
Oh, what's in-
[Loud creaking noise again]
Son of a bitch!
Don't do that!
Do I need to fix anything else?
Goddammit.
Okay, nothing in here.
I'm tryna be thorough about this,
and actually explore a bit.
It said I needed to go to
the bridge, but it's kinda more over here.
Oh, that looks good.
Oh, it's just a-
it's all just a big loop anyway.
So I can't go there..
Is that breathing?
Why is there breathing on the
other side of the doo-oh hi.
Oh good, oxygen tank.
Speaking of breathing.
[Growling]
OH
UH-OH
[Growling continues]
OH
[Footsteps]
Hi?
Where are you?
Oh, that ain't good.
Hi.
I wanna get a good look at ya.
Oh, hi!
Oh, you're naked!
Oh, you're not as scary now!
Uh, this is all sorts of bad.
This is every sort of bad.
"Bridge", "Briefing"?
This doesn't make any sense.
These things just send me-
[gasp] What is this?
Hi
untextured console!
Did I mention that this game
was a demo?
Why do I gotta do in the bloody vent?
And I'm not English bloody vent,
I'm talking about the vent-the vent's literally
covered in blood.
Alright, okay I'm goin'
in the bloody vent then.
[beep beep beep]
[beep beep]
Du duh duh duh.
No?!
NO?!
Then why did I come here?
There's no point to any of this!
What is that?
That doesn't help me.
This is a bunch of nothin',
I didn't even need to go in the vent!
I just could've gone around.
Oh, what is this?
I can't go here!
AUGH
It's an invisible wall over there.
Oh, jeez.
eee
Okay,
alright.
Okay.
Alright.
Oh, OH OH THAT'S BAD!
AH
AHH, HE'S COMIN' FOR ME!
Which way do I go?
I dunno-
aw, shit!
Shitty dicks!
Uh..Shitty tits!
Hi!
Oh, he's still after me!
Well, I'm boned!
LADADADADA
I'm dying of radiation.
ladadada
dadadada
Okay.
Oh, he's still behind me!
Ok, I think I lost him.
Alright.
Goddammit haven't I been here?
No, this is a different place.
EEE
HI!
OKAY.
HI, FRIEND!
WELCOME!
Ah.
OHH! HERE!
Let me through, please, immediately!
NOW!
OH, COME ON!
What am I doing? What am I doing?
What am I doing?
How do I get through here?
[beep beep beep]
[beep beep]
I DON'T KNOW WHAT TO DO!
What the fuck do I do?
Do I need like a keycard, or something?
I probably need a card.
Or a key.
Or a keycard-type device.
Or something of the like.
He's not nearby anymore.
At least I can get this.
OH! Okay, I thought he was there.
Alright, so I gotta-I gotta search
this place for something.
Oh, is this the armory?
No.
Just oxygen tanks here.
Torpedo base? Lifepod?
Why can't I just get in these things?
Why do I need to stay?
Why would they only send one person?
Doesn't make any goddamn sense.
Goddammit, I'm just backtracking now.
Nice, space!
[hiccup]
Dammit, I've managed to go
all the way back to the beginning,
which is not very helpful at all.
But maybe there was another way
to go, like over here.
Yeah, maybe.
There we go! Ok.
So this is a new section of the ship?
Yeah.
It definitely is.
[oxygen spraying sound]
Fuck you!
What-What kinda bullshit welcome
party is that?
Just be happy that I'm here,
I'm here to help.
mergiplier
helpful-helpy-helperton.
But I'm still in trouble because I
don't have any protection from the monster.
I'm goin' in raw~
Jeezums!
Where the hell is this?
I've never been here!
OOh! What's that?
Hello.
[Female voice coming from radio] "We've concluded that
the [illegible] intelligence feeds off radiation.
It seeks it out like a moth to a flame.
It then excretes a gaseous substance that
causes rapid mutation of organic cells.
Many who have come in contact with it have
choked to death as their esophagus swelled shut.
Those are the lucky ones.
Others have shown brain deformations resulting
in an increase in primal behaviors and agression.
It is fascinating.
I wish I could study it further, but it would
seem that I, too, have been exposed."
Oh!
Oh, that's so sad!
Oh, that story- [Loud roar]
Hi.
That's the noise I heard from before.
That's from SCP Containment Breach.
You can't fool me!
I know all about that!
I know 100% about that..
Who's there!
Who is there?
I've got radiation on the horizon.
And it's rising fast!
Uh oh!
It's gettin' close!
Does he HEAR me?
HUHH?
Who ever it is, they're very unhappy.
Hello.
Is that SCP-682?
eugh
[growling]
Aw, fuck me.
Where is he?
ee-jeez
ee-jeez, which way?
Okay, from down there?
Do I need to go to-
no I just came from cryostorage,
didn't I?
Is that where I originally came from?
Aw, either way I'm boner-owned.
He's comin' down.
Aw..
eee
W-I don't know where to go.
Hey, buddy.
Hey, hey, hey!
Can ya give me directions around here?
I can't see a goddamn thing.
This is a bad idea.
Hey, hey friend!
Hii!
How are youuu?
You good?
Oh, oh this spells bad.
Well, that's more than one.
There's more than one.
Why did that guy just stand there?
The fu-hey!
Hey! Hey! Hey!
[Loud creaking noise returns]
Woah, hey! Woah! Hey!
Oh-Kay' you get away from me!
Oh god, where am I?
Oh, jeez.
Oh, this is where I'm supposed to be.
Ah, shit!
Ah, fuck, I'm cornered man!
But they don't wanna come near me?
The fuck?
Is that for real?
Really?
So they don't come near me?
Hi buddy.
But they just stop.
Hey, what's wrong?
Ya shy?
Oh, come on! It's me!
Come on, take a picture with me.
It's okay.
AWW!
AW-SON OF A TITS!
Well, that sucked.
Alright, be right back.
Ahhh,
This would be helpful to me!
I did not know about this.
This is, um
hang on.
Everybody, shut up!
Shut up!
Shut up for a goddamn second!
Okay, hang on. Alright.
So, this is a map!
Who would've thunked it!
It's a frickin' map.
So I'm in cryostorage, so there's
a little icon of where I am.
There legitimately were two entire halves
of this ship.
So I was very wrong in my assumption.
I-I completely- I don't know how I missed
that there was a map here.
But apparently I'm a frickin' idiot,
so i'll be right back because I
am gonna go explore in the back end
of the ship.
Cause' there's gotta be-
SEE-EUOIOIOI
How's everything going over here, huh?
Is it goin' good?
Okay.
Alright.
It's good.
Friendly, friendly place.
Friendly friendly place.
Good.
Oh, hello.
Ooo, more life pods!
Hello.
[Female voice emitting from radio] "My shift is almost
over." Yay.
"If I can come in tomorrow, I'll be gone to sleep
for the remainder of the voyage.
Can't wait to see my little girl.
It's been tough, and especially for her.
She hates me for taking her away.
But it was really for the best.
You know, there wasn't much for us back on earth.
This way, we get to make a fresh start."
[Loud growling]
"Over here, at least."
It's really fascinating because there's a lot
of story here.
I mean this is obviously just a demo,
and the game is rough around the edges,
but there does seem to be a-
a really interestingly crafted story here.
And I wanna know more about it.
BIBIDY-BOO-BOOP-BADA-BOOP
LET ME OFF OF THIS FUCKIGN SHIP!
So these are the escape pods,
and it seemed like either people
used them already, or they're out of operation.
I dunno which is which,
but I'm gonna still try to find
the way outta here.
And apparently I'm headed to
the engine room.
I don't know why I need to GO THERE.
It's not like I'm gonna be able
to fire up the engines.
Oh, she-shit.
Is he in there?
Why is it so dark?
Why is it doark?
Why is it so dork in there?
I can't go in there.
Okay, that's why it's so dark.
It won't let me in there!
Ah, so I'm assuming with the demo
there's just areas in this game
that it's not gonna let me in.
[Loud creaking noise, yet again]
Shut the fuck up, I'm talk'in here!
Yeah, so it's just-it's not gonna let
me in there.
Alright, that's stupid.
Alrighty then, well here's a radiation room.
Can I go into the radiation room?
oooh
[beep beep beep beep]
[boop]
What the hell?
Hi?
What are you?
Are you just for convenient radiation baths?
Well this- this isn't even on the map-here.
This is unmarked territory.
Why is this here?
Are all the vents not on the map?
Might be true..
Apparently there's the armory
just around the corner here.
Armory?
Wait-
yeah..
This- is this not it?
Is this not it?
ARMORY?
Armory?
Ah, Jesus I can't go in here either?!
Why not just keep the door closed, then?
Don't give me false hope..
Oh, hello.
This is, um
dense.
eee
That doesn't sound good.
Wherever I am, it ain't good.
Also, being around these corpses
of infected people,
is that gonna-
is that gonna infect me-
oh, what's under the drape?
I don't wanna know..
Some kind of statue?
[Static]
(gorgeous face. so blessed. so pure 11/10)
uhh~
Okay?
What the fuck was that?
Why did everything go quiet there?
Uuhh..
I gotta admit, that was like
the creepiest thing that's happened thus far.
I mean, everything else has been
random haunted house noises,
but that-I thought that was a thing!
I thought I was gonna die!
Alright, can I get in the infirmary?
Is that a thing that I can
get into?
Probably not,
considering everything else
seems to be closed off.
Hello.
Oh, I can.
Oh, jeez.
Oh.
Well I already heard the story about
the nurse who was in here.
Or the doctor, whatever.
[illegible noise]
HEEEaah
What the fuck is that?!
You keep doin' random bullshit things to me!
Goddammit, it's scarier than anything
else in this goddamn game.
Alright, okay.
Carrying on..
Can't go in the engine room.
Can't go anyw-fucgin-where.
Uh..more story!
[Male voice coming from radio]
[illegible]
"It cannot be seen.
It does not exist in this world.
It comes fourth from the darkness to
take our souls.
It took my family.
Thought that I had died an honorable death.
But I, unlike so many
didn't want to cower in the face of evil."
Uh.
Uh..I have no idea what to say
to that because..wow.
Alright then.
Um..
Yeah, that's not good,
but I'm assuming that these aren't
entities from "the darkness".
Demon spawn, come to claim you.
This's gotta be bio-
whoa.
There's gotta be some sorta biology
to em' right?
Can't just be all chaos and..
curfuckleisnus
So I have to-I think I've been
just about everywhere.
The-
AHHHEYYYY🎵
Hey, hi friend, how ya doin'?
I'll go the long way around,
don't you mind me!
Don't you mind me one bit!
Oh jeez.
Is there another one?
Ah-fruCKLEKNUCKLE
Well shit, okay I'll go the long way around.
Don't you mind me! I'll be fine!
Alright, you have a good one!
fuck off..
eee
Aw, that's not good.
Oh, where am I now?
Oh, which way do I go?
HERRDERSHNERGAL
Okay, gonna go this way.
I'll circle back to the briefing room!
Ohhh~
Yess~
Goddammit, that guy is persistent.
That guy's way more persistent than he was before.
So I can't go through there..
I definitely can't.
I cannot.
So if I go down here,
I should be able to get somewhere
where I can get to one of these other rooms.
Yeah, this is-
oh.
Hey, hello there.
[Male voice coming from radio]"Only a few are left.
Lieutenant Lynch,
Corporal Beckett,
and myself.
We've sealed ourselves inside the [illegible] center.
Sometimes we hear them in the corridors outside.
They know where we are,
and there was nowhere to go.
Supplies are running low.
I don't know how long we can stay here,
we'll have to move
sooner or later."
Yep, sooner or later.
That's probably what they count on.
Ok.
Ah thank you, oxygen!
I need that,
even though I'm about to die and
I don't think I'm gonna be able to progress much more.
Because getting to the bridge,
uh, I don't think it's an option,
just because
If I can't go through there,
I think that's just part of the demo
that's not available yet.
So I'm PRETTY sure
Yeah, I'm pretty sure there's just
nothing left to do on this one.
As far as I know,
because there's just-oh.
Hi! Hello!
Hi!
Jesus..
Yeah, because if you go here,
and there's nothing that you can do,
because that won't open,
and you're just stuck here,
and I've been everywhere!
So it's not like there's
y'know,
It's not like there's an endless
list of things that you could do.
[beep beep beep beep ᵇᵉᵉᵖ]
Yeah, because this ones closed too,
so I dunno how to get to the bridge,
and it says 'search for an officer on the bridge',
so I don't think I can get in there.
The objective marker is there,
so I'm assuming that it's just undone.
But this is good framework, here.
There's good story here,
and there's good..
like,
Uh, there's a good world to open
up a whole lotta things-
and I'm getting radiation poisoning right now,
and it doesn't feel too good,
could you stop that? Thank you.
That's all of this game for now.
If you find more stuff to do,
let me know down in the comments below.
I'll provide a link for this game down in the description below.
So thanks again,
and as always,
I will see you
In the next video!
Bye bye!
[Outro music♫꒰･◡･๑꒱]